[Music]
very often when you think about robots
we think about machines like these guys
they're very much products of their time
but now where we build robots today
looking forward into the future those
robots reflect that as humans we're
having a bit of an identity crisis
all the things that make us uniquely
human perhaps have been eroded but what
we can see from these robots is that
they are not just a recent phenomenon
stretch back at least 1920s and it's
fascinating you can go back even further
than that
five hundred years ago the word robot
didn't exist but people lived in a world
of mechanical people most often they
were found in churches places of worship
get crucifixion scenes and a lot of the
Bible stories re-enacted using tiny
mechanical people these are reflections
of the gain of industry or technology
these are reflections of people's
religious faith and their devotion of
their sense of belief people who are a
fronting a wealth and status to prove
and to show off realize the power of
automata so rather than being czar sound
in churches increasingly find these
amazing mechanical people theatres in
cabinets of wonder these amazing places
the lathe is an amazing demonstration of
the massive power of machines what you
have here is a machine which could
completely without any human
intervention produce a tiny detailed
piece of wood turning its parlor
generation of machines which could write
and to play musical instruments and it's
a very potent reminder of how a machine
can be used to demonstrate the power in
your body a person who owns it Sue's
Industrial Revolution technology came
online leaps and bounds by the 1920s
we're living in a mechanized world
factories and mills power looms cars
Henry Ford and that sort of environment
breeds some amazing new ideas which
languages the film metropolis which has
Maria first brought us the robot
robots imported the most astonishing new
technologies things that aluminium
batteries or electric motors taken
squeezed together and created into these
new robotic form two robots like Eric or
Saigon or the torch and all of them
stand up and they can move and they give
speeches make presentations and people
marvel at from their marvelous machines
what happens next people work through
how do you make a robot do these things
to go from recreating the making them
for these mechanisms of the mind
so since they've all been building these
robots which don't just have these great
big steel bodies but they actually
behave in lifelike ways as God behavior
is affected by the nature of the body
that the robot resides in as it learn
all and building these great big steel
things why don't we build robots which
are base much more closer on human
anatomy so Rosa the robot you can cleat
here is what we call an anthropometric
robot what that means is that her design
mayor is very closely the anatomy of the
human body
the moment when you program a robot you
use up the machine codes but
increasingly people are saying why do
build robots which respond to
conversation or body language that sort
of thing
incur from beginner 21st century was
used the reception in college in London
was giving out directions she a
character she could talk he brought her
dress sense and comment on the weather
nuts inside so a lot of modern robotics
is placing the mechanism of the bottom
and with mechanisms mining stop together
a new and exciting way
but that's only ever happen in the
laboratory and the big question is when
robots escaped from the lab ended in at
the turn of the 21st century robots
finally look like escaping the lab in
entering everyday life robots do all
sorts of things like jobs are da la da
more dirty or dangerous happening some
building cars to clearing land mines but
what's really intriguing is just how
many other things they could do another
really big question is what we want
robots to look like on the one hand like
a dome boys we might have robots which
are absolutely lifelike with hair and
with face expressions and they're very
uncanny to us or robots could be like
Robo festive who's absolutely robot
light with aluminium skeleton and all
the insides on display there's no
artifice there one thing is really clear
however however robots look or what
happens with the next that decision is
not in the hands just of roboticists or
engineers it's with you
we've been reinventing ourselves
machines now I completed an assassin
fascinating almost completely forgotten
story as we built ourselves as robots
we've basically built a whole series of
mirrors and nature of the scope of those
mirrors change continue big question is
where do I own future robots have been
automatons in future perhaps there might
be machines that can think or even have
consciousness where do we go next robot
big question as you have
you